[Music]
what's up guys it's bobby and i'm back
to talk to you about what i consider to
be one of the most important products
you can have in your home when it comes
electronics it's not the smartphone it's
not the laptop not the computer it is
the tv
to me the tv is the gateway that feeds
our soul some people say it's the eyes i
say no it's the tv because this is how
we consume our content right yes we use
our smartphones yes we use our tablets
our laptops our computers but when we
want that optimal visual audio
experience in our homes
we turn to the tv
anyway xiaomi sent me this tv a couple
months back to test out it's their brand
new 75-inch tv so i said great let's
send it over and i've been very
impressed with it not without its faults
but i think this tv is something to take
a look at anyway here are my thoughts on
the xiaomi mi tv q1 q175
on my wall
let's talk about this bad boy
all right guys before we kick things off
i do want to let you know i'm not paid
or sponsored for this review these are
my thoughts and my thoughts only i'll
talk to you about the features of the tv
the build quality what it's like to use
the pros and the cons and all that stuff
now i do know it's very hard to judge a
tv
from seeing it on youtube you're not
gonna see the optimal image quality
coming out of it so you're gonna have to
trust me a little bit on this one and i
hope you guys do so with that let's talk
about some of the features first off
this is a 4kq led tv it's not oled it's
q led as you guys know oled obviously is
the superior image quality but it comes
out at a much more expensive price point
qled offers a lot in terms of image
quality not as good as oled but it comes
at a lot more affordable price points so
this is good for a lot of people out
there that are on a budget or maybe want
a secondary tv for their home or for
their room or whatever it may be okay
now this has a 120 hertz motion
smoothing to it it's an hdr 10 plus
display uh you have dolby vision to this
you have access to netflix and disney
plus and amazon and google assistant
it's an android tv now unlike other
xiaomi tvs in the past where they were
coming from various different countries
depending on where you shop from this is
english based so you do not need some
sort of plug-in for it as soon as you
take it out of the box it's english
ready it's good to go this is a major
step up from xiaomi it is qled
technology so it has improved and it
comes at a very good price point i
believe around in singapore it's going
for around two thousand four hundred and
ninety nine dollars plus there's some
giveaways if i'm not mistaken and xiaomi
always has promotions so do check with
your local store check online if you're
in the singapore market or in other
markets around the region for what that
price is besides that let's talk about
the build quality now this is not the
thinnest tv out there qled tvs tend to
be a little bit thicker obviously
because of the technology versus oled at
his thinnest point it's four centimeters
thin but it does bulge out towards the
middle and the bottom of it of course
you have these speaker systems in the tv
that do sound really good i'll talk
about that in just a bit but also it's
where all your ports are your three hdmi
ports your usb 2.0 ports your auxiliary
inputs all that stuff so that is all
here in this tv and of course it isn't
the thinnest but once you put it on the
wall you're not really going to notice
much of a difference on it um it is
almost bezel-less i would say there is a
slight black bezel right here there
abouts but you really don't see it
unless you're watching it on television
and of course the silver trimming here
is right to the edge it is a beautifully
made tv
it's very nondescript you actually just
see the xiaomi logo right here at the
bottom of the tv that is it just as me
so when you put onto the wall it looks
very sleek it looks very expensive it
looks very just classy also the display
has a little bit of a gloss to it so
this is why i'm shooting at an angle
because of course you'll get the
reflection coming from the lights here
and you might even see a secondary light
that's coming in from the background
that is just sort of the reflection i
try my best for the optimal viewing
angles to shoot this video but
it is what it is um but when you're
watching it at home at night uh the
lights are down you close your curtains
there's no issues at all with that um it
is reflected but not to the point where
it's really a big issue even when i'm
watching it in daylight like this as
soon as i'm laying on my bed here i have
no issues watching the tv
now let's talk about the remote control
for a moment because this is going to be
something you're going to use a lot and
the remote control is very intuitive
it's very simple to use you have your
netflix button on there you have your
google assistant button to access it or
you can say hey google your prime video
button on this as well so it's all there
but it it works well i mean it's durable
i've dropped it a few times hasn't
broken it's great simple intuitive easy
just like the tv let's talk about the
speaker system on this tv because you
know normally i recommend getting a
sound bar getting a speaker system now
in my bedroom i use the bose sound
system it's a wireless sound system it
sounds fantastic about i've also used
the harman kardon citation one sound bar
which sounds fantastic as well but the
speakers coming out of this sound really
good um it does give you a nice dynamic
range to it it doesn't sound tinny it
doesn't sound hollow it can fill a room
pretty good now again if you're an
audiophile you're going to want to set
it up your own way
but
if you're on a budget or if you're in a
smaller room and you're worried about
the sound coming out of this tv do not
be it actually sounds really good uh
especially for the price point
now when we look at image quality this
is where it gets really tricky with
television sets and this is where it's
gonna be harder for you guys to see on
youtube
versus what i'm seeing here the angles
of you are actually really good this one
if i go to the far left to the far right
i actually still see the image it's very
clear i don't see any sort of distortion
or any sort of color change it pretty
much stays consistent which is a nice
thing not like i watch my tv on the side
i usually sit right in the center that's
the optimal viewing angle but if you're
that kind of person that does for
whatever reason you're setting up in
your living room or your home and you're
gonna have t chairs on the side or the
couch on the side you don't need to
worry about that also in terms of colors
this is a very vibrant tv and obviously
you have a lot of different color gamuts
that you can choose from you can
customize this as well
now it might not have all the tools of
customization that you're used to using
let's say on other brands out there that
are much more expensive but there is
quite a bit of customization in this and
you can really fine tune it to what you
want it to be but you might be limited
in some regards now there is an auto
dimming feature but i don't find it to
be exactly as good as other tvs that
i've used especially for example lg for
that matter but it does an admirable job
for what it is but when you really want
to brighten this tv up it can get very
very bright so
normally when i'm in bed at night time i
turn the brightness down very low to
like 12 or 10 because it really strains
the eyes especially if you're in bed and
you really want to watch something and
it's dark in your room it can it can
really be overbearing now this tv has a
120 hertz motion smoothing to it now
this 120 hertz motion smoothing there's
an asterisk to this because
it only applies to what watching content
on android tv if it's netflix or if it's
youtube or
you know disney plus or whatever it is
whatever content you're streaming from
android tv if you go into gaming like i
have the ps5 here i cannot set it to 120
hertz now for a lot of gamers out there
this might not be a big issue because
look you're probably using your pc or
using another device to game on but if
you want future proofing this might be
something to take in consideration
unless xiaomi updates the tv if they do
that would be fantastic but it could be
a hardware limitation we just don't know
yet but in terms of watching videos or
movies without that motion smoothing
personally for me
i turn it off because it just makes
everything look too videoy and too fake
and that's just not how i want to watch
my television i mean some people do i
guess but when i go to like a consumer
electronics store and i see these tvs
and they're playing all this demo
footage and it looks just
fake because of the motion smoothing it
just turns me off completely so that's
when the first things i do when i go get
a tv is i turn off motion smoothing so
for me it doesn't make much of a
difference there's a lot of
customization that you can do of course
it is android tv and so you can of
course add a lot of different apps to
this and whatever the app store has on
android you can put on to this there is
some limitations when it comes to
android tv i won't get too much into
that now that's a whole other video but
uh for the most part if you're watching
you know a lot of the content like
disney plus netflix hulu all those
channels cw
cbs whatever it is whatever country
you're in you will find those channels
on here
and no issues at all playback is great
video quality is fantastic it all looks
good and it performs great this is a
very fast tv in the way that it performs
it did going through the menu system
selecting items there is no delay
whatsoever so what are some of the cons
to this tv um well number one is
it is q-led which could be a con for
some of you out there uh to me
personally it doesn't bother me so much
i've had oled tvs in the past and qled
it still looks really good and to be
honest with you unless you put two tvs
next to each other you're not going to
notice much of a difference that's my
personal opinion yours may vary if
you're a video file you might be yelling
at your computer your smartphone when
i'm saying this right now but
you really need to have two tvs next to
each other oled and cuellar to see the
much of a difference but once it's in
your home
it looks great image quality is great
the colors are fantastic there's no
issues at all with in my personal
opinion um however that
limitation on the 4k 120 especially when
it comes to gaming is a bit of a
downside because this was one thing that
i was excited to play you know i was
playing a spider-man miles morales on
ps5 i wanted to see the optimal image
quality coming out of this unfortunately
i was limited i was sitting trying to
set it up and i'm like why is it
allowing me to select this in the ps5
and then i come to find out that there's
that limitation so
that's the one of the hiccups for me on
this tv okay so my final thoughts on the
xiaomi me tv q175 is this a tv without
its faults no no tv is right but for the
price point i think it's very impressive
yes i would love to see 4k 120
especially for gaming maybe this can
come in a firmware update maybe it's a
hardware um issue i don't know yet i'm
still waiting for final word from xiaomi
on this but
if you're not into gaming that much
you're just wanting to watch netflix or
disney plus or hulu or amazon prime or
whatever content provider that you want
to watch you know your movies and tv
shows from
it performs great the image quality is
fantastic the viewing angles are nice
you can fine tune the image as well if
you don't have a speaker system the
speakers out of it are okay it will
definitely do the job and
it just looks really nice
i really like this tv to be frank with
you i really do um so those are my
thoughts on the xiaomi mi tv q175 let me
know your thoughts in the comment
section below though is this a tv that
you're looking to pick up are you gonna
pass on it i would love to hear from you
guys on this anyway follow us on
facebook subscribe to us on youtube be
safe out there and i'll chat to you soon
take care
[Music]
you